the Dead
hey guys whistleblower22 here
sorry about the gap between videos I got
kicked out again
but I promise this new scoop will be the
biggest of my career to be honest once I
expose this I fear for my life
it's time for the truth a footage is not
gay
the story never added up not coming out
until its 30s were coiling from any
physical intimacy with his alleged
husband the Deep state has gone to Great
Lengths to cover up and rewrite mayor
Pete's history because not only is he
not gay people to judge is a plant he's
been hand-picked by vice president Mike
Pence to run for president and then once
installed in the White House you'll sign
an executive order to create Pence's gay
conversion camps it's been Pence's plan
all along and when President Trump
didn't agree Pence went with Plan B plan
but a judge
thanks for watching announce I'm gonna
shout out everyone who contributed to my
GoFundMe started with Mr Patrick S
so yeah guys thanks for the support
we'll splatter out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's what I know
[Music]
yeah I made a lot of movies in the 80s
paid handsomely yes
yes I was
ah stuck on you then they stole the
title for another movie all right anyway
hello and Ahoy Ahoy and hello happy
Monday uh Steven is out today but I am
going to be at the big chair in the big
chair not at the big chair I I I'm tired
too
the fact that we do this show early is
uh Stupid all right so I'd like to
welcome everybody to the show uh today
we have a great group with me as usual
Gerald a how are you I am better than
you sir are you well you know what I
gotta say to you what's that happy
birthday we missed it yesterday oh look
at that
[Laughter]
it's definitely not really because you
have just the iPod that we found which
is weird because it's old but I mean you
still have those yeah yeah and it's it
just I thought it was a zoo it wasn't it
was weird he's always like hey guys are
you gonna bang that one in your Zone
we're like could you stop talking like
that Dad it's that old generic MP3
player yeah
foreign
casiana Jones Ahoy good morning Tim good
morning Gabe and of course our very
special guest not his birthday but let's
throw him one two
happy birthday to me here we go
quarterback Eric oh no that's even
better
for any reason whatsoever and let's
confetti me
we all get confetti today wait wait wait
while I slurp go homo
some dreams do come true fantastic Do
You See Me Now Daddy
[Laughter]
hit me with my confetti yes do you like
what I do now you said this would never
happen yes but here I am is that but is
Rip Taylor still alive oh yeah I think
so right yeah oh please don't don't tell
me about if he's dead or not I don't
want to know I I assume the hive got him
anyway what
that's what he would throw out of his
bag pieces of AIDS victims all right so
anyway today we'll be talking about
Kanye's Jewish tweets Gerald knows
Sports streamer breaks streamer breaks
Crimea Bridge blows up Buddha judge new
road and the right stuff app fails which
is shocking yeah I did not see that
coming no and also the question of the
day is what is your opinion of dating
apps do you think uh the conservatives
only dating app should work can it work
go ahead comment because uh you know I
don't no no way did you ever date app no
no no I found my wife before all this
stuff was real so I don't know what
slight swipe left or right or I do I
know those things I went through with
one of my grinder yeah what's that for
hoagies
I I know that I know that yeah or you
can order a hoagie yeah I know that one
that's yeah if that's what you want to
call it yes nine inchogies yes I like a
12 inch
there's above average yes above average
Hoagie apps
they're sloppy I need a bib
um
you didn't did you do the app I did a
couple of apps yeah did you do Christian
Mingle uh
uh I think there was a Christian app
that I did uh well no it was something
else ebony love no it wasn't
no was it ebony off there was two one
was really popular totally blanking on
the names yeah I did not that one not
not no okay
the harmony there we go oh Harmony which
was more of like a classic that was was
that for old people yeah pretty much
like our time is that what you did yeah
that's right before they spun off into
our time
our time should be called out of time
yeah come on hurry up yeah so you have
10 years left they were all like it
should be called hospice of time so yeah
what terrible did you did you meet your
wife on that I don't mean to be personal
I thought you met her normally I did yes
no offense
on a nap I didn't mean it like that I
thought you meant like like a regular
person yeah yeah a freak yeah not like a
weirdo nothing somebody's at home who's
like ah that'd be crazy not like that
app where you take selfies in the mirror
and don't get any hits how do you meet
people in these days though like it's
got to be hard no idea no clue
whatsoever school and work you know
normal ways
you're 47 you go well I guess I should
try an app right well but how do you go
up to somebody and just go hey Sunday
you know yeah and then check the
carriage yeah is that what you do no
yeah you put your hand under there and
check for heat
is Sheila I just need to know if there's
a bunch
oh how do you go with somebody and not
just expect it and be like hey you look
nice and they just pull out a whistle
yeah exactly all right geez again
wouldn't you just feel like you'd be me
too at any Corner hey could I buy you a
drink and you're like why am I being
cuffed yeah gotta be terrified I just
want to give you money oh that's even
worse yeah
that's that would seem like the safest
way to get sex though
because you get a guarantee yeah and
there's just yeah just give cash it's a
transaction it seems you know it seems
right oldest profession legalize sign a
contract that you happen to have in your
pocket I just have these printed out I
know they have an app for that right
they have a consent app do they really
I'm not even joking I thought that was a
stand-up bit is that real that's a real
thing you have to consent now they're
just gonna say that you took her and put
her fingerprint on it when she was
passed out who invented that cost Bill
Cosby's like I got all of them look at
all these fingerprints yeah okay Bill
that's something
what consent app it's like hey we're
about to bang by the way do you mind
consenting please I just don't want to
get me too it's like anybody out of
people that do get me too that's like a
necessary thing it is oh yeah you have
to go I have consented yeah can you
imagine sitting at the table I'm not
sure how this night's gonna go but just
in case I trusted her enough to have sex
with but not enough to keep her story
straight oh there's a QR code and you
give a voice statement oh wow
that's such a terrible time can you
imagine this is a better dystopia we
live in you're back at the apartment we
can agree on a safe word coffee cinnamon
winter Peach Orange
is the app listening for the safe word
so it triggers yeah and then it starts
up an alarm it's going on some cops
immediately yeah isn't the nine and one
buttons on the phone a safe word yeah I
thought so all right couldn't Siri call
the cops for you serious safe word yeah
hey take your hands off I did not
understand that could you repeat
I'm being right yeah Alexa rape
that's playing music yeah he just
triggered it in someone's house yeah
It's Raining Men no no the Rogue
playlist
[Laughter]
speaking of Music look at that Segway
there's beautiful man can we do the
Washington react oh we didn't I didn't
it's almost right over that was our
Watch What A Silly Billy I am I wanted
to get right into uh right into Kanye I
mean hell yeah I wanted to get right
into Jesus
so all right let's uh go ahead and uh
take a look at this watch and react
Kanye West is being canceled by big Tech
is this part of it yes
Kanye West is being canceled by big Tech
but there's no need to panic because to
take his place we have a nine non-binary
fraud that's okay to flub because it is
stupid non-binary broad who claims you
hate her because you won't partake in
Her Fantasy check this out I can be
masked I can be found cars and gender
fluid I am not binary I go by there
all right acted don't use that one too
why don't you like me why don't you like
me is it because you're a tough it's
your haircut it's everything about you
there's the whole package stupid haircut
yes why what's a Turf again
it's a uh you know what I don't even
know I pretend I know but I'm not sure
don't tell anybody I'm sorry it's not
she her it's the they them a Turf is a
trans equal rights feminist right
something I thought it was the opposite
yeah it's a bad one is she a Turf
somebody's determin genders oh it's
against something it's a feminist that's
against them oh because they always call
JK Rowling I thought she would know she
looking to choose from Harry Potter she
did look like Harry Potter if he just
ate cake yeah
a trans exclusionary radical
what don't like trans people right okay
say it again I'm sorry trans
exclusionary radical feminist oh Trans
exclusionary radical feminist yeah ding
ding I see so she is a norm
she's just complaining she doesn't have
any friends and she's blaming it because
they other feminists dang turfs okay
right instead of uh being a fun person
or having a personality of any sort she
felt to go to tick tock and sing yes the
person singing to their phone alone in
the room yeah it's complaining that they
don't have friends that's crazy
boy that's how I made all my friends
growing up was speaking to my cordless
what an idiot why don't I have is it
because I look like Michael Moore banged
Harry Potter I have a little Christmas
haircut and hey my ugly home the problem
is you yeah it's not me
I don't like trans why because I I'm
often mistaken for all right anyway
remove from Tick Tock what are her
pronouns I don't they them but her fun
fantastic Dax Dax was they's name I
don't know if I like anybody named Dax I
don't need a little too forward you know
you're expecting me to just accept your
name Dax yeah Shepherd I'm talking about
but I think he made it up uh yeah I'll
give a damn Shepherd is her name Dax no
no no hey hey they's name is they named
X
see that's the thing I don't know they
is they is
guess who they is named ax oh look at my
baby his name's Dax come on just name
him Tom or something something regular
something that won't get him beat up
later just to be clear anybody in
preschool and up just gets an A in
English now yes okay it's like I don't
know maybe yeah
they is that store a plus it depends yes
that is your truth I can't correct you
that's how we stop please tell me how
you meant it
good Lord ebonics is Shakespearean
all right yeah and it is actually it's
true it's fantastic it's actually
because you understand it you understand
any language that's not what we just saw
right speaking of singing
[Laughter]
the Yi the Yeezy Kanye West maybe you've
heard of them uh he's uh he got a little
bit of trouble for some tweets and
rightfully so I have to be honest
um he's lost his mind a little bit some
time ago I I have like Kanye in the past
um he's talented he's a talented guy
very talented man he's a lot he's a
little out there ups and downs you know
George Bush doesn't care about black
people does not get fish stick jokes no
not at all
not at all what about Lady Gaga right no
then he jumped up on stage with the
whole Beyonce thing so he's been kind of
like a wild card forever this whole time
so I don't know why people all of a
sudden being like whoa what's going on
with you he's always been this way yeah
tried to take what's her name's uh
Grammy yeah Taylor Swift Taylor Swift
yeah yeah which I I mean sure I mean
yeah
she wasn't gonna be using it he's
already got like 15 of them yeah she's
good enough she's fine yeah she should
need another one she wears mom jeans and
I'm not saying she's not cute but yeah
it's enough that's a terrible push in it
it's why people are breaking up with you
laughs
so Kanye West has been locked out of his
Twitter for anti-semitic comments and uh
the tween question which has since been
removed we're going to go ahead and read
it this is not something that I agree
with any of these no not at all what you
said he can't say stuff like this but he
did no he did so he tweeted I'm a bit
sleepy tonight but when I wake up I'm
going to I'm going Defcon 3 on Jewish
people whoa Jewish people all caps on
the Jewish people why because this
Ambien you know I swear you do Tucker
one time
start going off in 12 takes
the funny thing is I actually can't be
anti-semitic because black people are
actually Jew
also you guys enjoyed with me and tried
to blackball anyone who ever opposed
your agenda
I didn't know that quarter black was
also a quarter Jewish did you know
you're partially Jewish wow that's
interesting what are the chosen we're
gonna we're gonna call you 18th Jew yeah
take that let me change my Twitter
handle right now yeah if you go ahead
okay go ahead and do that Kanye taught
us something you look at your stocks
you're like I'm rich
somehow I always got an email
wow welcome to my club email I own way
more gold than I ever knew I uh start
investing land that was Hebrew yeah yeah
Hebrew yeah it's the the poor Hebrew
which is well it's it's it's Hebrew
German it can be a lot of things but
there are Landau Hebrew German that's a
word that's a crazy it's a crazy mix
because I think that's why I hate myself
so much I don't know
a lot of internal yeah just I want to
exterminate myself
terrible but you're trying to wheel and
deal at the same time yeah I mostly also
yeah Irish and Italian which we're not
people who love themselves either well
Italians are but we're loud
anyway
many outlets are covering ye going after
Mark Zuckerberg on Twitter uh
independent Fox Yahoo
is that a thing all right look not yet
oh wow
yeah the three resources are independent
Fox and Yahoo I was kidding G
independent look at this Mark how you
gonna kick me off Instagram
okay oh that's not the whole tweet no no
no however they seem to be omitting the
closing words of this tweet we have them
for you here and Gerald is going to read
the tweet in its entirety for us
and go go look at this Mark how are you
gonna kick me off Instagram you used to
be my n word
terrible thing I can't I'm not too
popular sing it I say it but I won't
take your channel down can you say the
first quarter words yeah
you want me to read it no no I think we
all know what it is okay
it's not it's not a fun word well it is
well the way that it has the way it says
in that Community it's fun to listen to
or rapping alone in your car
or in Chinese remember the the video
that we had of the guys or what NBA
players were getting off the bus and
they were in China yeah and it's it's
pronounced that way
there's a there's a French basketball
player I don't know why it reminded me
but his name's like Lil fat hoe is it
really low fat hoe or something you
gotta look it up basketball player he's
a basketball player little fat hoe it's
not little but it's like something fat
hoe oh I'm gonna get the jersey and wear
it all the time
also not being covered is Kanye's
follow-up tweet
who you think created cancel culture oh
oh boy oh what are you trying to say
what are you trying to say
go ahead comment below who do you think
sorry to cancel culture Mel Gibson yeah
I agree
I think when he called the cop sugar
tits that's what he did but seriously
comment right who do you think created
it honestly
was it
j-o-os I think that's what Kanye is
alluding to is that what are you saying
yeah I don't think it was pretty much I
don't think so either I don't think
Jewish people are responsible for most
of the things they've been blamed for
yeah
I mean something more thing because
people are just people you know oh
people just like people they're gonna do
things they make mistakes but I create
cancel culture according to ye according
to Yi yeah I don't understand how they
would get together I don't any people
group how do you get together and create
cancel culture I think it's just
individuals doing it and then
conspiracy theory out there that I'm not
aware of I'm just tired of blaming whole
groups that's why there's so much
division in this country because we're
like yeah all of them you know stupid
you sound maybe it's just all uh
[ __ ] it's that maybe that's what it
is right and it doesn't necessarily you
could be white black Asian you know
whatever it is yeah
I'm gonna do a diagram yeah do you need
a whiteboard let's say this is all
people right yeah can you see that that
looks like okay okay um and then right
in the middle oh boy
[Music]
and these people
these people are the problem it's a
cross section and they're the ones that
want to keep it divided that's why it's
divided in the middle there yes that's
where all the [ __ ] comes out
thank you you are an artist why why did
you not hit the more you know thing I
can't even imagine well we did the drum
rolls oh thank you you have a drum roll
into the morning I almost felt stupid
it really is just like just I it's not
who created cancel culture honestly the
media people who wanted to jump on
things and that's what he would say uh
well yeah
it is
I always have an answer for you yes
exactly and I'll tell you that's right
that was the people in Banks which again
is I'm saying if you're not listening to
me you're not listening by the Ducks
like they're also mind controlled by
okay fine if ducks have cameras in their
eyeballs yeah yeah that's true that's
why they migrate so they can watch you
all season long well you know the song I
thought it was pigeons it's pigeons too
so it's all foul waterfowl the Ducks are
watching watching it's not a song from a
distance all right dear duck voice
dude can you do a duck voice yeah well
it doesn't really get their voice do it
do Disco Duck
[Laughter]
I do a lot of words with that you just
end up screwing it up and it's hard to
do on the the fly I could do that don't
rape me one because that's pretty easy
you just sound oh that's a distressed
duck that's the one that's the one
you're comfortable with practice that
one a lot I do
I feel like it'll turn any would-be
attacker off yeah so just be like whoa
what is going on here he's doing
impressions you just present yourself
and start quacking
I hope that's a corkscrew penis
look it up it's disgusting
it's like right next to the cat penis
you know how they have barbs what yeah
they do yeah messed up animal Kingdom's
sick you know what else cats have huh
big claws when you try to bang them yes
but
Dave what are all those scratches I just
want to love you
I'm just coming every day with ripped up
clothes yeah I don't have one shirt
that's not ruined no man's going out
Dave even for cats what what's going on
with you I volunteer at a cat sanctuary
yeah yeah but why are they always
clawing you beats me you're really
aggressive man yeah I don't know they're
mean cats they're not all declawed
that's why I'm sometimes happy now
obviously what Kanye said is
anti-Semitic and Twitter is well within
their rights to take down uh overtly
racist tweets I fully agree with that
and statements but I mean and then again
you know yeah I'm gonna say I don't
agree with that because let us know who
the [ __ ] are I don't really care I
really don't care what you're right I
understand if they're gonna have a
policy I guess the point is to enforce
the policy on both sides and it's
interesting there are some tweets that
we've got some overlays of that are
still up and available
right we I love it when white people get
what they deserve after centuries of
enslaving and murdering black people I
want to see more people get mutilated
and beat up because they deserve it okay
so that's allowed that's acceptable all
that pretty red f white people I mean
they call the the the call starts
December okay so oh they're calling for
a race right they're they're calling oh
happy go lucky white people it's white
people just for you old people in the
room uh make me want to hurt somebody
there's only a few good ones that's you
know a little wow so those things are
fine I need a list seriously name one
good white person I know
nobody difficult
[Laughter]
nobody
is this is this December 4th
I don't know if it was like are we late
I don't know is it where do I play I
don't know that was in 2021 oh it was oh
it's okay thank God we survived the call
so it's not this Christmas will be
pummeled no yes make it one more year
it'll be mostly peaceful it'll be mostly
peaceful pummeling yes good that's
fantastic I like hearing that wow that's
good all right but I was worried well
those those three those tweets made it
through so remember
and this should be a more you know
moment yes if your tweets are racist
make sure it's at whites
they're lesser humans
I can say that
yeah I could say if I wasn't if you get
canceled because of that I would just be
like they pull this [ __ ] I'm sorry
that's hilarious yeah
nope Dave you can't even say that about
yourself I I can't it's because I said
and I was a Jewish last name they rip it
off the internet they're like can you
believe with this heat I said
but he's not really Jewish it's just the
last name
the real last name's Donald
huh my real last name is it oh yeah my
dad took the name of the guy who raised
him ah because the Irish dad left the
day he was born because the Irish back
then
sword of scumbags back then left for a
pack of cigs yeah did he well the Irish
for the original you know
use
it's not that is true
take a check really aggressive check
alcoholic that's a little different well
that's true we swapped a crack that was
all us
I love you I love you too I do for real
which side of him
the white side oh of course what did you
think I was referring to racist I think
of the back side the three quarters
this is a live show Monday through
Thursday at 10 A.M Eastern oh we're live
yeah this is live yeah it can't be
edited I find that it all could be cut
out yeah
oh well I find out the hard way every
day where I'm like oh well that's
permanent
bonus this is a live show
this is unfortunately a live show Monday
through Thursday at 10 A.M Eastern
usually around 10 10 uh 10 15 but go to
rumble check us out there look at that
Rumble look at the rumble like in the
Bronx or in the jungle oh Rumble in the
Bronx yeah it's such a classic I like
that movie
what's your favorite Chan
movie
who am I I was gonna say who am I yeah
who am I dude good call boys I do good
call you never seen that I've never even
heard of it give it a watch oh okay dude
you gotta watch it like when's it from
early uh 80s probably oh yeah yeah it
was before it was before Rumble in the
Bronx anything after rush hour
just kidding rush hour one you're like
Rush Hour three rush hour one Rush one
is great run is great one is great I
said like I said it like watchable
jacket can't run
three I don't know if it's real
there's a third one I I thought there
was yeah yes yeah there is right what do
you think of the tourist was it the
tourist with when he's the father Johnny
Depp no no no no no that's Johnny Depp
you can not the tour sorry it's the uh
The Foreigner oh yeah oh I haven't
watched his recently I wasn't I mean the
movie's not great don't get me wrong but
his part wasn't bad I liked him in uh
what was it Pariah parasite
[Music]
in a bunch of movies yes the human
centipede yes yes he was the one in the
front
his name is Asian person yeah
what's your film credits uh centipede
number eight yeah you just take a trip
to any Asian country and ask everyone
for Jackie Chan's autograph you're like
I don't think this is the trip for you
you're not gonna make it happening
well let's talk about some other Giants
not just little ones the big ones the
New York Giants Sidelines got a little
weird over the weekend I don't know if
you saw that on Sunday the New York
Giants defeated the Green Bay Packers in
London 27-22 uh that brings us to this
week in Gerald no Sports
three stars
[Music]
now the Giants may have won on the field
but the real show happened on the
sidelines
[Music]
we call that unnecessary fluffness
so Gerald uh you played football uh
explained yeah
um
I didn't know that was available on the
side
okay sometimes you need to pick me up in
the middle of the game I don't know what
that's supposed to help
I thought you wanted those guys angry
and mean that's just gonna make him calm
and relaxed I was gonna say he just
doesn't [ __ ]
doesn't that usually take the drive out
of you I know because if you wake up in
the morning you're like I think I'm
gonna paint the shed and then you do
that you're like I think I'm gonna do
nothing I'm gonna take a nap rest of the
day I was gonna go in and kill a
quarterback but I guess not no by the
way he also looks like a five-year-old
at a urinal you know kids just like drop
their pants
like half cheeks it was weird you have a
medical tent you have an entire thing
set up where you could do this in the
privacy of your own tent DeSean Watson
yeah you can go over there and do it he
just sits proud he put a 20 in his shirt
that was weird
what was he really doing because uh to
the angle of all the kids all the
children watching at home watching the
game
what's that peace that he needs
brotherly love right there oh we want to
make sure he doesn't have a hernia or
yeah you know that's how the Giants roll
yeah
that's how that family when they go to
sign free agents this is going to be on
the brochure like this could be you
angry on the sideline need a little help
look we don't pay our assistant coaches
just to stand there
what do you think it was for real dig
deep yeah you really gotta get in there
uh an inner thigh groin kind of thing
could have been rubbing somebody yeah
milking his prostate I'm gonna be the
first person to say this but I think
Sports is pretty gay it's not gay look
at him
NFL is gay yeah I'm gonna
be a little gay they need to rub like
you know some ointment on your leg or
something yeah if you're having a muscle
issue or something you know what I got
it it's just uh you know it just could
have been done better yeah either the
coach should have said you do it yeah
or the player should have said I got it
you're right somebody should have
stepped into this situation you know
what's funny though watch the player's
left arm it kind of looks like he's
helping okay oh look at that he's
cradling that's what he's doing what do
they call that one if you're going to do
it do it right yeah yeah he's like look
I'm gonna cup him yeah you talk look
there's a Tempo feels like there's three
of us
I'm gonna sit on my hand to listen no
and it's gonna be like a stranger yeah
it's gonna be like this bunch of us here
I like when people watch it's London I
guess we can do this on this yeah do you
want to go in the locker room hell no I
don't want to go I'm an exhibitionist
all these people see me in the locker
room and no
and that's been General no Sports
[Applause]
[Music]
at Notre Dame they just bring out the
phrase
please I'm sorry I thought this was
junior football I'll pass
oh I'm sorry you're an adult yeah that
sucks
oh the priests are judging us ew hey oh
this is gross
sorry I know it's not I thought this was
Peewee
so let's talk about a
twitch streamer it's a good title for
her yeah because it's not like she's in
porn no
allegedly no not a legend she broke her
back right not not doing what you might
think but uh We've we've all heard of
the expression of adult stars getting
their backs blown out yes uh but Adriana
check I don't know how to pronounce it
Adriana
took it to a new level over the weekend
at twitchcon
[Applause]
great Victory there she broke her back
yeah the funny thing is concrete under
there lady
she's not fine
now she lives in the pit now I kind of
think
yeah that's too bad she had gone on all
fours she could have lifted herself
right out she's used to a lot of load on
her back a lot of the her muscle
strength is there yeah it's all for all
of them yeah it's all in the exercises
maybe she should have she could have
probably gotten used to it if they were
like just through a towel ladder
the guy from the previous video
the the workout guy with the oh oh yeah
yeah yeah she doesn't work out those uh
she had pulled muscles a fluffer I think
she had to look at the camera and name
the establishment
about mascara ran down her face
oh my gosh
she clam slammed herself did you see
that though she like full-on like boom
what what is it on the ground I don't
celebrating Victory what else is she
supposed isn't that a place where like
children have birthday parties like
isn't that like a Sky Zone that's that's
not quite what it is no it's it's a
conventionally constructed pit yeah it's
a convention hall which means there's
concrete right there oh she was just too
stupid those foam blocks are not enough
to you know they didn't dig out no a pit
for you lady how's she gonna work all
right well lay there yeah yeah anyway uh
okay
she broke her most valuable asset that's
true yes her tailbone yes
no action going on down there
uh note how coverage of the story refers
to her as twitch streamer not a single
mention of her actual Revenue Source in
the article Adriana confirmed the
severity of the injury over Twitter
well I broke my back in two places and
I'm getting surgery to put a a meter rod
in for support today a meter Rod is the
name of her new co-star
and it's more just a measurement yeah
send your support when it rains it pours
and I'm definitely feeling the rain
right now all over the place dripping
everywhere surely the first time Adriana
has had this raining down on her we
actually have footage of the surgical
consultant who will be performing the
operation
[Music]
bummer
pizza man yeah
he's really a true hero just a
well-rounded sir yeah he does it all
indeed a jack off of all trades
real man of the people yeah
or on the people yeah or around the
people yeah so we wish her well we
really do I don't want to speedy
recovery yes I don't know I don't want
to see anybody get injured I do no it's
okay yeah the bad part is like you're
like ah she's fine she's used to being
in the pit you know it's like oh your
back is actually broken no that really
sucks for real I do I do hope she's okay
yeah I mean that's not she's gonna
regret that life choice
let's just put it this way you probably
should regret a lot of Life Choices
this one will be immediate this is
probably a second I can't believe I did
a toe touch to celebrate why couldn't I
just walk off yeah two will be our fault
the third was her uncle's yeah and then
she couldn't tell at first because it's
just all numb down there yeah the third
will be when you're 50 and look back and
go
surprise she felt it yeah
bam oh this is like a regular day at
work yes this hurts more than usual
wow I can feel
yeah normally when I slam all right
anyway
let's talk about Pete bootage yeah
speaking of do you know Pete yeah Pete
yeah Pete Peter
Pete South bending big old booty [ __ ]
South Bend where Notre Dame is no it's
next I think we just saw him on the
sidelines just not too long ago a
correction well it is located adjacent
to South Bend it is
adjacent to southbound we created our
own City when we moved there in the
1800s we foresaw the crab hole that
would be South Bend and said no no no no
that's Notre Dame's facts
Gerald knows Notre Dame that's right
yeah
yeah she's working on it oh man there's
a river that separates us for a reason
I go to Detroit a lot um well I'm from
there but I went downtown to see
concerts and I kept going why is this
freeway shut down that goes to all these
places you know like uh every single
sports arena and concert venue why are
they shutting it down this would be an
odd yeah shut down a highway
beautification project maybe you'd
assume yeah uh or you you maybe not that
one
but anyway Pete Buda judge got Detroit a
106.4 million dollar Grant to turn a
Detroit Highway into bike lanes because
it deflates families and jazz clubs in
the 1950s
the purpose of transportation is to
connect
but we have seen examples of cars
communities including here where an
infrastructure decision serves to divide
and we raised this issue not to wallow
in it but to challenge ourselves to do
something about it and now we are
putting our money where our mouth is oh
I bet you like to put stuff anyway and
it's not important yeah but a lot of
stuff for your mouth is
uh the ground was part of a 2021
bipartisan infrastructure law
infrastructure law
[Applause]
graphic for all sports events and it's
completely uh it's a completely
different area now like never once have
I driven through this area and thought
you know what would be good riding a
bike through right here completely
unprotected yes well it's physical it's
funny because this whole plan right so
this was built through a neighborhood I
think it displays like a hundred
thousand people when it was done but
theoretically I have no idea this is
prior to the race riots
long long time ago 50. so now they said
it's like oh this is why this area is
bad it disconnected to a community so
we're going to tear this down and we're
gonna put up a six Lane Road and bike
paths what is the difference so you're
taking down the bridge of a highway
which we can walk under you're putting
in a road which we cannot walk under
yeah that's that's fantastic you get
really idiots which first don't
understand the booty [ __ ] I guess get a
higher brain capacity well because
anybody leaving a Lions game is not
drinking and driving from depression so
there's no chance of them just barreling
over bicyclists you know we want to just
cut to the Chase and get them dead so
they don't have to suffer all the pain
exactly of being a bicycle by the way
105 million on a one mile stretch of
road wow mile that seems consistent with
the Democratic party though it's like
all their plans it really is isn't it
that's why I wanted to bring it up
because this it'll ruin traffic it'll
mess up everything it's way too
expensive and it's a lot of money while
Flint still has lead in its water that's
what bothers me the most and I wanted to
bring it up about Michigan these are
real people who have had this problem
and all of a sudden that's just not an
issue even though how long has this been
going on what seven years with Flint I
know people have lost their houses I
know people have lost their children
their families and we're going to go
ahead and go you know what I saved the
day I stopped a racist Highway we
actually
um we actually have an interview with
somebody though who is going to talk to
the highway uh if we can go ahead do we
have that uh we have somebody on the
street
he's in Detroit right now are you there
talking to the
all right now
okay yeah oh man I hope they get into
somewhere safe okay like out of the city
that was a bad idea
oh they've been killed all right so
um we're gonna need a new camera
all right
so anyway this getting back into it
um foreign
maybe we should take that money and
instead of deciding to stop a racist
piece of concrete
[Laughter]
if we could use the money to I don't
know stop poisoning people of Flint that
could be a decent idea and if you want
to actually talk about racism and
everything else it's not really racist
there's white black every single person
in Flint a piece of Highway cannot be
racist it's cement yeah just my opinion
but who cares about you know water
because you can get a filter if you ask
really nice for one in Flint which
brings us to today's sponsor water
did you know earth is made of 71 water
doctors recommend we drink at least 1.2
liters of water a day just to be on the
safe side that's a lot of water water is
key to our survival but we don't just
drink it we have fun playing in it too
we wash ourselves in it and sometimes we
even get stuck in a storm of it an
adult's brain is 65 Water and the other
35 percent is gin
but maybe that's just me
my wife left me
and she has full custody of the children
that there that's Jeff
my kids call him dad now he's a lawyer
in fact he's her lawyer I remember when
my wife used to brag about being married
to a Big Time commercial voice over guy
that was a long time ago when she
used to wear her ring
we used to actually have a house on the
water but now it belongs to the bank
luckily it was only in my name so only
my credit got ruined
thank goodness I'm still able to afford
this studio apartment it has this pot
I'm currently filling with water
this pot is the only thing my wife left
behind besides pain I'm gonna use it to
make some macaroni and cheese
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
water drink it unless you're in Flint or
Mexico or Jackson yeah that one is bad
too yeah Democratic old cities
by the way we uh canceled the check to
that voice over actor we feel like why
would you do that well you didn't
deserve it I mean he was we wanted to
push him over the edge well yeah oh it
actually didn't clear anyway no uh he
did a sponsor for Walther and it didn't
work out didn't work out
should have seen that coming yeah
anywho
are bad
I think originally my idea was to add a
gunshot no
it was
oh
you can't make bullets out of it one of
the beautiful things about writing not
to you know to let people in but yeah
Gary can go with that is always adding
the one extra thing at the end to get
away with everything else very important
distracts from all the other things
you're right like I'll shock you with
this so you don't hate me for that yes
maybe the hanging legs at the end of it
was just a little too yeah it looks like
Brooks was here too yes oh
well we got to get in some serious stuff
guys uh over the weekend I'm sure you
guys have heard about this Russia
Ukraine thing I hadn't but I guess
there's some business going on and
perhaps we're on the Eve of Destruction
go ahead Google that song play it in
your Zune who knows Ukraine blew up the
Crimea bridge on Saturday the lone
Bridge connecting Crimea to the Russia
Mainland exploded in Flames
[Music]
watch the truck up the highway you've
probably seen this
hey yes I would
must surely stop or keep going depending
on which side of it I would keep going
this is like the aftermath right so the
train that was passing as well is just
all on fire and flames and I mean it's
almost like a twofer for those guys I'm
not sure if they planned it when a train
was passing that was carrying fuel oh
geez so um yeah well an unnamed
Ukrainian officials said Ukrainian
intelligence was behind the attack I
wonder
wait you mean all the yeah but the good
guys
the good guys in Ukraine hey I feel
we'll get into I put a flag totally bio
on Twitter this is totally weird about
this I spent 19 on a shirt yeah 19 whole
dollars yeah so I did something
good job Dave I didn't do anything no oh
sorry oh well you must be canceled well
yeah look what you did yeah it's my
fault
you did this it was mostly on me
Stephen King is blameless yeah
the Ukrainian Postal Service announced
that they will release a commemorative
stamp early next month
so look look this is a big is that real
real yes it is it gets worse wow I
couldn't have wrote this this is just a
big finger obviously this has strategic
importance right being able to access
the uh to know what's going to happen to
your mail yes pretty much
um
bomber uh yeah please accept no but this
is also can you imagine Ted Kaczynski on
one of our stamps yeah it's just a
commemoratively attendance it's just him
with a hoodie yeah just hit uh but it's
not only that they're they're actually
they actually had this was hours after
the bombing by the way they actually had
a giant stamp for people to pose in
front of us look at this
wow what it looks like real even if it's
not real these guys are trolling them
epically but were people killed uh I
don't know if anybody was killed I hope
this side bomber the car closest to the
truck looked like and I say suicide
bomber because even if it's not
terrorism it's still somebody who's
doing this and bombing and they're dying
right yeah well if you're a suicide
bomber that's on you well and if it's if
it's a military action that's a totally
different thing yeah right so that's why
we'll get into the wording there but
it's really I don't have any idea but I
know that this is you know you can see
what Russia's response is here in just a
little bit obviously they're a little
pissed off about it and they're sure
people for it so it's just funny that
these guys are like throwing this out
there like on the day of and by the way
this happened the day after Putin's
birthday
wow happy birthday so no matter what
side of this you come down and you're
like that's pretty that's pretty epic
trolling right there did you have a
Putin cake for your birthday I did not I
am not a Putin fan really I'm also not a
fan of the uh the Ukrainian corruption
either I don't want to tell us every
time the cameras are off yeah every time
just cut oh I love Putin it's like don't
you guys love Putin see when he rides
that bear I want to believe it he has
nice tables I'll give him that remember
when he brought in that dessert he
invented the Fig putins yeah I thought
it was tacky but yeah just like the joke
they were tasty
ingredients were so good it's only the
fresh the only dessert I could think of
Karen if you walk do you remember New
York during the BLM rights the Fig
lutons oh geez it just keeps going yeah
all right ukrainians are already posing
in front of the giant stamp we covered
that part and one month earlier on
September 7th the Ukrainian Ministry of
Defense tweeted the weather forecast
says it is going to be very hot in
Crimea wow this is a lot of trolling
yeah I'm telling you that's the whole
point of this story it's not gonna be
this happened it's like right hey
they're trolling the hell out of them it
really is it's it's time for the uh the
rush Invaders to prepare for a swim it
takes a lot of strength to swim to so so
Shia or yes yes yes
he just had his Twitter suspended and
the last one is uh BTW the Guinness Book
of World Records may include a new
record for the longest Open Water Swim
wow this was a month ago I'm waiting for
a diss track I know right they gotta
drop a diss track I love how bombing
threats include BTW yes it's like FYI
gonna kill your family Loki Gonna Die
thanks for telling me wow that is so
weird so yeah it's all funny it's
trolling it's kind of funny I'm sorry it
is that's the ACT necessary no but no
and the stamp the stamp is because
nobody likes Stamps no unless you count
me in my every last collection of stamps
once in a while there's a person that
likes stamps and they're like yeah we're
gonna put it on a stamp
oh commemorative yes
can you imagine you being on the stamp
of
the bridge I would love that yeah we'll
say this Russia does have tactical
nuclear weapons by the hundreds if not
thousands so which it almost seems like
very excited to use yes yes it's like oh
you want to put us on a stamp here we
have a new stamp yeah looks like this
yeah it's gonna be fun when you lick
your stamp with three tongues
look it glows in the dark yeah it didn't
before they start tweeting out I wonder
what medicine you can take for radiation
poisoning
yes Putin always known for comedy big
table
doesn't play a piano with his penis
though no what have you seen my table
yes it's a big table pretty big just
like penis
big piano too big to play with penis
Vladimir Putin responded calling the
bombing a terrorist attack
there is no doubt this is an act of
terrorism aimed at destroying Russia's
critical civilian infrastructure
some conservative pundits also echoed
Putin's sentiments Ian miles Chong's
shared a video Ian miles Chung you don't
like them no Ian okay look so Ian miles
Chong is somebody that lives in like the
Philippines yeah never set foot in
America but constantly tweets on the
right wing but he's not right wing yeah
well this kind of helps I guess so if
you if he's if he's tweeting don't
retweet him he's full of [ __ ] is he live
in the Philippines I believe so I
thought he was the gay gentleman that
had a concrete milkshake thrown at no
that's a different guy no that's uh Andy
no Andy Andy no is a pretty good guy I
like him not all Asians no I forget that
this is Andy now I'm it's early and I
got confused NGO I didn't mean to be
offensive
I'm sorry Andy I very much like your
word he's a good guy he is Ian I don't
know you and you don't know me anymore
[Laughter]
I blocked you I blocked you in Miles
strong shared a video of the explosion
with the caption
video footage of the terrorist attack
that blew up the Crimean Bridge yeah so
this this goes to the point Garrett like
you were talking about I don't know
about me and my I've seen some of his
stuff and I've never really liked it
look at him very often with his
responses on Twitter but this is like
look it's not a terrorist attack in the
sense of a word like hey we're just kind
of doing our thing and you guys showed
up and did something bad it's like we're
bombing the hell out of your country we
also annexed part of it we annexed this
particular part of it in 2014 our bad
and then you guys retaliated so you can
say it was a suicide bomber because the
guy is going to kill himself by blowing
this bridge up that's that's fine but to
say it's an act of terrorism doesn't
quite ring true and for Putin to be like
oh my gosh it's a terrorist attack on us
it's like well what do you expect you're
an open War their entire country come on
what do you want these guys to do
apologize yes you can have the bridge no
this is perfectly fine have we made the
Crimea River joke yet no I was waiting
for you to do this it's pretty good I
was even hoping somebody had a sound
bite of was it TLC or was it
Justin Timberlake Justin Timberlake oh
he sounds like a [ __ ]
yeah TLC could kick his ass dude I love
it yes he's great dude rest in peace
left eye
I'm sorry my girl left eye left eye I'm
TLC passed away passed away I don't know
the names
don't lie like you don't like TLC
you know hip-hop but I didn't know the
names I'm not kidding this guy he chases
waterfalls yeah I am and they don't want
no scrubs no no remember that please
send them they're best friends ride and
the passenger side trying to holler at
me come on uh just stick to the rivers
and lakes too okay I have a problem with
the lyrics of the songs don't want no
scrubs yeah yeah she doesn't want
doesn't want a scrub I wear it's a
double time
negatives anything ebonics and it means
double negative I mean scrubs there is
hope for you I don't want no scrubs
trying to swim a river river
ever don't go chasing cry me your phone
whoa
doing a mashup yeah I love it when the
radio station Monday mashups awesome
Crimea Monday mashups Monday Monday
Monday don't check the bridge
gonna be a hot one
hope you can swim yeah put on your
floaties crabby Aruba
um
yeah but TLC left I died unfortunately
after she had a pretty rough life anyway
yeah yeah and uh she's pretty badly
abused by the football player she was
dating I believe Ray Rice oh so uh no
but yeah she's not a different football
player I know it's kind of crazy I know
right right rice can hit a woman so hard
that it closes a casino that's
impressive wow
I mean that's that's got to be the got
to play again I think right didn't he
get reinstated at some point he did yeah
it's a violent sport
it's like you can do that to linebackers
wow I put that guy in the field
paid a lot of money to do it minor
defense of yours cameras in an elevator
I was trying to make a point
I drug her onto the elevator I was gonna
take her yeah well he won the argument
Andre Rison
yes Andre Rison now I don't know if
that's for sure right I know that there
was there was allegedly an issue with
them and one of them set the house on
fire I can't remember it was pretty it
was pretty messed up that's weird she
had a lot of issues but they she I felt
bad for her she really had a lot of time
one of the best parts in house party
three yep yeah she's pretty great in
that movie yes she was
yeah and house party one and two
Robin Givens Robin Givens Givens yeah
I love those movies every single one of
them dude they're always party one two
and three somebody brought it up this is
gonna be a side here but really the
American Pie Robin Harris my bad the
American Pie movies are a carbon copy
but a white version of House Party 100
they're all the exact same movie yeah
the pie well yeah same thing you have
you have the house party at the end of
the movie everybody's dancing everything
and then the second movie is about them
in college where they have another house
party right and the third one is a
wedding where they have another house
party yep it's the same movies only
house party is a better movie yeah well
it is I agree and if you ever asked a
black dude to have sex with a pie he'd
be like no and they'd go all right we'll
rewrite wonderful
hold on what kind of pie
no still no still no
also for our Superior film Friday oh one
of the best films ever in my opinion
movie so much dude I got to work with
John Witherspoon a couple times and
really TV show with them pops why he's
from Detroit I loved that dude
Witherspoon is just a class just a
legend man dude just the coolest guy and
he was from Detroit so I brought him
Vernors and better made chips and he was
like oh dude he was so excited because
he hadn't had him in years his brother
actually was killed he was a Motown
singer really and I didn't know that
about it yeah he was telling me about it
really cool guy dude one of the coolest
people I've ever imagined with man who's
so funny anyway sorry not to break off
into that but I just want to say he was
a cool guy anyway uh Russia speaking of
not oh yeah I'm not cool guys like Putin
even though not a big fan big fan not in
response this launched a series of
attacks on Kiev uh Warning by the way
this is very graphic seriously so please
if you have kids don't let them see this
next part it's it's very unpleasant
foreign
attacks not just there but around the
country this is the largest series of
attacks that they've had since the
beginning of the conflict and this is
obviously Putin's response
um to this and he went on TV and said
that this was a terrorist attack and
that the responses will keep coming in
this manner as long as they keep
fighting back I think was his thing so
if Ukraine stands up for themselves if
Ukraine does anything to try and slow
down the Russian military or fight
against them
then this is the kind of stuff it's just
escalations after escalation after our
escalation sounds like we should
continue funding it yeah it sounds like
this is on a uh you know Elon Musk type
of track that he kind of predicted
Millions so billions billions anyway but
the really funny part though is this
next part so we try to bring you a
little bit of Comedy right so they
effectively blew up a bridge to start
this whole deal and so Russia decided
that they were also going to Target a
bridge it was a pedestrian bridge though
and so no Scenic Overlook for you if
they destroy this thing but here's we've
got footage of them trying to hit this
bridge
there's no audio no audio
just a nice you know walk bridge for
people to walk on oh oh and they're like
we got it it's like an independence day
that's a direct hit
I think oh hell they're not a son of a
gun it's still there
wow
they did you six Roman candles as the
bomb
great job Russia is that a way to scare
them
you'll know if you hold them like this
and then they explode yeah they might
hurt your hands them all together it's
so terrible it's like a great jukebox
your sparklers that guy you know whoever
was in charge of targeting there is dead
now right oh yeah he was killed
immediately you you were going to die we
could not blow up pedestrian bridge It's
Made of Glass what is this what is this
nobody even there nobody there Putin is
not known for his sense of humor no he
is not long tables no sense of humor no
that's what he's known for if he had a
sense of humor
they have a lot more backing him you
know I feel like yeah I feel like if he
calmed down for a minute and was like
you know what I'm kind of a dick yeah
and also I have a lot of introspection
he needs billion dollars
I could be just fine yeah you know I'm
all right yeah I know Russia owns like
the most land in the world so this is
all I should just check it out I think
why do I have to be a brick why why do I
want power so much weird I've got a lot
of it I mean
Ukraine it's your country I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm kind of a dick and we're
leaving so I I don't know what's gonna
happen but I think uh I think we're kind
of uh
I just think this is really sad I don't
know how far this is gonna go I don't
know where else it's gonna go what do
you do it's a completely different
country with the whole history behind
each other and it's like yeah well
here's something interesting to pull up
CNN really quickly if you can North
Korea missile tests were nuclear attack
well not because of that because oh look
it's a lady in white
lesbian and white he's shooting Rockets
with me right well no I mean it's it's
with choppy cheeks cheeked
[Music]
um
it's just nonsense no sorry but I guess
the broader point is that these guys are
flexing their muscles a little bit too
which means shooting Rockets kind of
indiscriminately over Japan we saw over
here last week they had the the missile
alerts and then the tests are and you
know a test of nuking the South which is
something that the United States has
always feared because there's not a
whole lot you can do about it because
it's so close so I mean this is just one
of those things where it's like it'd be
great if we had some good world leaders
and people to step up and de-escalate
situations like this instead of
people who forget what we have a lot of
ways they're supposed to walk
you mean instead of an old man who you
wouldn't give a butter knife to to
whittle true yeah that guy well
seriously somebody has to do something
how many we're seriously on the brink of
something terrible potentially yeah I
mean potentially I don't want to scare
anyone I mean obviously people firing
off nukes and threatening them and stuff
why would that upset you well what do
you think is going to happen whenever
you have the entire Western World look
weak
as hell and then of course you're going
to have the evil countries or people
that are evil running those countries
coming out and going okay well let's
start pushing the boundaries let's see
what we can get away with let's shoot
Rockets over other places like that's
what we're gonna get whenever you do
stuff like every year of 2020 and 2021
all of these bad decisions make you look
weak yeah and you're not gonna do
anything about it yeah not even just
weak completely submissive yes yeah
completely capable of doing to you what
they do to their own people yes yeah so
we'll see where this ends hopefully this
all de-escalates what you get we get
some leadership in here that uh takes
care of this because I certainly don't
want there to be
a full-scale war breaking out no even
more that involves all of Europe or
potentially involves Japan North Korea
South Korea like this just no it's just
a hellacious scenario now these guys
could be just posturing right this is
something that they do often where of
course they don't want to look weak or
they maybe want to leverage this so that
they can get something out of it but I
don't want to go down that road because
what if they're not I don't want to
allow that possibility to happen so you
have to have power and that's something
that we've forgotten well they may be
weak like think about this what if
North Korea is completely weak
militarily right the old but only thing
they have is nukes so they are not weak
right because they have nukes if you
have nukes you're not weak
like you just cannot be weak because you
have that option deep thoughts
right but you can you can be weak enough
to use nukes yeah am I ages
is that what's going on folks but like
that's what I'm saying is like you can
get pushed to the brink where you go
okay my only option is
the nuclear option right your only
option is the unthinkable yeah and we're
I think we have a uh I'm reading a
really interesting book about Black Swan
Black Swan events are these like I
watched lesbian type events
not that different movie
um we're really bad at predicting
whether these things are going to happen
or not and these are the things that
these are the kinds of situations that
breed them right very lots of
uncertainty lots of weakness lots of
posturing lots of No Way Out scenarios
like Putin can't look strong Putin just
launched that attack by the way
everybody's like oh this is the biggest
attack
10 people died that's terrible but 10
people died that's not Putin being
strong yeah that's not going to be
looked at like we won that's going to be
like okay well we sent some drones in
and shot some Rockets what else are we
doing because we're still at full scale
war with these guys 10 people
so people just start having to ratchet
up the body count to appear stronger to
their population to stay in power so
that's just a bad place for us to be
yeah yeah evil isn't necessarily a
strength the problem is is you have
different kinds of people in this world
and one is a peacock and one is a lion I
honest I feel this way no seriously
think about it I like it you have a
peacock where you have somebody who's
testing nukes doing stuff like that and
they're trying to show that they have
some kind of hand but they don't really
have the ability to use it or want they
just want to seem powerful the problem
is is if there's a lion they just kill
you they don't tell you they don't talk
about it it's like death threats yeah
it's like are you going to Instagram me
or death threat I don't feel threatened
oh they just kill you so the problem is
is one of these
somebody comes out of nowhere and
decides to do something that's what I
worry about not so much the people that
are showing off and playing this game
it's what's in the shadows yeah and
which one of these people are finally
going to be the person who just goes oh
that was the crazy one mm-hmm
we'll see who knows waiting for the
opportunity um
just an opinion that's true we get to
talk about a softer subject wow that was
a poor choice of words
[Music]
yeah I love that book that's not a book
no
she turned into a Black Swan in real
life it's freaky man yeah that was a
good that was a good movie for like a
dancing there's 10 minutes of that movie
that I loved I was like yeah 10 minutes
yeah it was the end when she's dancing
[Music]
dude Kutcher's lucky
um
are they still together yeah this little
thing yeah they didn't stand for Will
Smith at the uh Oscars and then they
were like yeah we didn't here's why and
I was like I like you okay all right
and he never disliked him I know he's
made terrible movies but I don't like
that because you like the guy yeah yeah
yeah people give them a lot of crap I
don't just like them before and her oh
oh hey speaking of the the glass bridge
that we were just talking about that
they attacked notice what is right next
to it
so you okay you probably can't read that
yeah yeah it is so this is Google Maps
that is an EU headquarters Wishbone what
um
right I understand with you yeah wow I
didn't what's the message
European Union yeah I knew that
that's crazy
we'll see I'll just have a message
people that didn't know that's right
we got to talk about a dating app yeah
anyway
we do have to go to mug Club here in
just a second uh behind the paywall but
we want to let you know we're gonna be
talking about a dating app the new app
The Right Stuff uh go ahead subscribe
you should come on it's what pays the
bills it's what buys this sign and
please join us we appreciate you so much
leave a comment talk about how great I
am talk about how great quarter black is
talking about how great Gerald is and be
sure to dance like nobody is watching
and laugh like you've never loved before
I don't know the quote footsteps
foreign